we very much have a wee mentality where
we believe that everything's better
together there's this idea that when you
do things as a community
you're gonna achieve much more I'm
Miguel Garza CEO of yet their family
foods and I'm 29 years old
the CFA makes healthy delicious Mexican
food primarily Dorothea's we are a
gluten free product we're a grain free
product we started about two and a half
years ago
[Music]
there are six members of the goddess of
family working full-time that's yet they
it's great and difficult being in a
family-owned business so I'm the baby of
my family and I am the supposed CEO as
well so at the same time that I have to
lead and cast a vision for the company
if we're all getting in a car my oldest
sister can still ride shotgun
[Music]
we're seeing this push towards small
food businesses local food businesses
people making niche products that solve
problems people are just starting to
realize what they're putting in their
bodies the marketplace is reacting to
that I don't think that we are relegated
to the ethnic food aisle although I do
believe that Latinos are gaining both
influence and affluence in this in this
country and I think that you have
cultures from all over the world that
are gaining influence in this country
and I think it's like a really beautiful
diverse thing so when we're making
healthy delicious Mexican food what
we're doing is we're using what has
become this global supply chain to make
heritage inspired innovative products I
think minorities start a lot of small
businesses but there are struggles that
they have you know the biggest one
probably being access to funding access
to capital strategic investors or
strategic advisors what we're trying to
do as a company is be successful so that
we can try and lift others up
I really can't tell you why we've been
successful I can't like pinpoint it but
I think that there's an enormous amount
of integrity and love coming from our
business our first core value is family
first business second and we believe
that wholeheartedly